- If you could sit next to Howard Schultz
at a board meeting, which I do.
I sit as close as I can.
Breathe on me.
Give me a little bit of it.
He said you don't go and
watch video from when you win.
You watch video from when you lose.
It was one of those things where you think
you're going to go in and
you're going to make a pitch
and they're totally
going to shoot you down
and then ultimately they say
yes and you're like holy shit.
(group laughs)
- Hello Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey
we're going to learn from
Ariel Investments president Mellody Hobson
and my take on her top
10 rules of success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best
and as always, as you're
listening, if something really
resonates with you, there's
a message that really
holds true to you, please
leave it down the comments
below and put it in quotes
so that other people
can be inspired and
when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Be a fanatic.
Warren Buffet supposedly interviews people
and he says are you a fanatic?
And when you meet the
fanatics, you know them
and I don't use fanatics in a bad way.
You know, it's this, the
people that I most admire
have so loved their work
and so wanted a good outcome
you understand why they're so successful
and when I think about our
young leaders of color,
I want to tell them just, you know,
it's never going to get easier.
You think it gets easier, it doesn't.
It never gets easier.
I'm still doing homework every weekend.
I'm still, it never gets
easier and if anything,
the stakes go up so much,
you actually have to work even harder.
You have to be fanatical.
You do not give up.
You don't take it so personally.
You figure out how you're going to get up.
Do not let people talk
you out of your dreams.
Do not let them tell you no
and you own that you
have to convince them.
I've spent time with
people who are world class.
I know what world class looks like
and I have to bring that
back to my organization
and bring that to life for them.
But I can tell you with the
people that I spend time with,
I am learning world class from them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And so therefore I have big dreams.
If you could sit next to Howard
Schultz in a board meeting,
which I do in every --
I sit as close as I can.
Breathe on me.
Give me a little bit of it, you know?
Look my way.
No, I'im joking but I sit as, you know,
I'm watching how he
watches, how he's studying,
how the presentation's being made,
how he's interacting with
people and I am learning
and I want to make sure
our people have that same
level of energy around this.
That's because that's what world class is.
Do not make decisions
based on money, none.
It's the worst way to make a decision,
which I know is so hard to say.
I mean I didn't grow up with any money
and I know so many of us are,
our families have a lot at stake.
They put a lot into us, made
a lot of sacrifices for us
and you say you don't have the luxury
of doing that, but I
actually think you do.
You will be more successful
if you make decisions
based upon what is
going to feed your soul,
make you feel value, valued, validated,
you know, have you
waking up in the morning
and racing to work, whatever it might be,
and I can tell you after
a short amount of time,
money will not be enough.
At the end of the day, a
bigger paycheck is another suit
or more real estate, more square footage.
That's what it comes down to.
You end up with another
room and a fuller closet.
And after a while, that's
not going to do it.
I read this quote during an
obituary for Floyd Patterson
the boxer and he said he only
learned from losing a fight.
He said you don't go and
watch video from when you win.
You watch video from when you
lose and it is the failures
that build the character,
that make you smarter,
stronger, tougher.
I was told people were scarred but smarter
and I think that is a really thing to be.
You could build on all
that accumulated knowledge
in a way that can serve you and
your clients or your company
very very well, but there
have been, you know,
numerous moments of great
pause and reflection
where I've sat and say,
and I say to our team
and I say to myself, what is the universe
trying to teach me?
That idea of I'm not
looking out five years,
I'm looking out long-term,
I'm not thinking about
there's another job for me somewhere else.
I'm thinking about this job right now.
Those are the kinds of
things that, you know,
I think have been able
to lead to my success.
When I started working
at Ariel, our founder
John Rogers said something to me
that I have never forgotten.
On my very first day, he
took me to TGI Friday's,
big spender, and he said every game
in life is won with
patience, every single one.
And he said I don't care if it's dating,
to you can't win the Indianapolis 500
in the first lap to a basketball game.
If you look at all
sports, just a very simple
just one sort of portion of the world,
patience is how you win
and that has been something
that I intuitively got at that moment.
I think when I think
about what I'd like to be
remembered for, I would
like to be thought of
having been very kind,
who did right by society.
I actually learned that
probably in my most
formative years from my
business partner John Rogers.
I actually just read a graduation speech
that someone gave at
one of the universities
about kindness and I
thought that he really
spoke to everything that
John started to tell me
when I was 22, that you could
always take the kind path
and you could win with
kindness and I try to think
a lot about that and
it doesn't always work
and sometimes I know I'm
not as kind as I want to be,
but it's in the back of my mind a lot.
I sit a lot of rooms with people who wait,
wait for someone to say
something or my favorite line is,
I give this all the time.
At Princeton, we had a
professor and if you were
in the preset group with
him and someone spoke
and you said I want to
reiterate what Sally said,
he would say you mean iterate again,
which meant you have no original thoughts.
And so these are the kinds
of things I think about:
have an original idea,
be willing to speak it
because it will get you noticed.
I love to swim so much that as
an adult I swim with a coach.
And one day my coach had me do a drill
where I had to swim to
one end of a 25 meter pool
without taking a breath and
every single time I failed
I have to start over and I failed a lot.
By the end I got it, but
I got out of the pool,
I was exasperated and tired and annoyed.
And I said why are we doing
breath holding exercises?
And my coach looked at
me and he said Mellody,
that was not a breath holding exercise.
That drill was to make you
comfortable being uncomfortable
because that's how most
of us spend our days.
If we could learn to
deal with our discomfort
and just relax into it,
we'll have a better life.
I think there was a very
specific risk that I took
very early on at Ariel that was
unique and unprecedented at the time.
I was about 24 years old.
I had been there for a
couple years and we had these
public mutual funds
that were in partnership
with another company and I went to
our Board of Directors and
said we need a divorce.
It had never happened
before and we pulled apart
two operating mutual funds
from an existing mutual fund
family, $400 million in
assets, paid $400 million
for the right to do it,
it was the whole nest egg
of the company and that was
a very, very, very bold call at the time.
It was one of those things
where you think you're
going to go in, you're going
to make a pitch and they're
totally going to shoot you
down and then ultimately
they say yes and you're like holy shit.
(group laughs)
They're not supposed
to be listening to me.
Don't they know I don't
know what I'm doing?
But it ended up like
marrying me to the company.
- Right.
- It's where Ariel became mine.
Now on a day to day basis,
what I'm now pushing
very hard and Catherine Berardi is with me
who is my teammate at Ariel
and a spectacular superstar
and she's heard me now say
this story like 100 times
in four months, but my new
thing that I'm really pushing
very, very hard especially
with women and my friend
Sheryl Sandberg is also
doing the same thing
in her own magnificent way,
I can't even compare myself
because she has a book
that's coming out on this
idea, but I feel like
as women, the risk is
us speaking our truth
and the story that I'm now been telling
is this story that I read
about a woman in a magazine
who said every single
day, every single day
her daughter walked out
of the house starting
when she was a very small child, she said
the exact same thing
to her every single day
through college.
Be brave.
Every single day.
She said she wrote her letters in college
and she always signed them be brave
and that now just speaks
to me because I'm in so
many rooms where I feel like
the courage is not always there
and I don't know what the fear is.
Maybe it's the fear of
not saying the right thing
or not fighting in but
I'd rather the person
totally, you know, make a giant mistake
than not say anything
at all and I just find
with women, sometimes we're really sort of
waiting to add our voice
and I don't mean to say this
in any way that diminishes us
because we have the good ideas,
but you know, when I was at
Princeton in our presets,
our small groups when
we weren't in lecture,
they would say something to
you that if you were piling on
with what someone else said
and you say I'd like to
reiterate what this
person said, they'd say
oh you mean iterate again
and that was their way
of making you see like that
is not an original thought.
- Right.
- And I feel like a lot
of the women in the room
have their original
thought, in some situations,
and are waiting to be
validated and I'm just like
go for it, go for broke, pound
the tables, speak your truth
and I now notice it in
ways even in my own firm
where I give people real life examples.
We had a board meeting
recently at our firm
and one of my colleagues
who's a superstar woman
was presenting and she was
only looking at our CEO
when she was talking and I was like,
don't ever do that again.
It was like she was
looking for his validation
and all the other people around the table,
it was like they didn't matter.
And I was like, it just made
you look small and you're not.
And that was like a simple
example of that being brave.
What about her needed to lock on on him
and have him nod and you
know, have her keep going
versus just owning the
room with her presence.
Stand up for what you believe in.
Do not back down.
And that doesn't mean you have to do it
with a fist in the air or
you know with aggression.
You can do it with grace and I cannot
be talked out of what I believe.
Now that doesn't mean, like
I mean in my core values.
You cannot convince me that
racism will ever be a path
to something good.
You cannot convince me
that excluding people
ever leads to a better outcome.
You cannot convince me of that.
I will not be moved.
I will not compromise that point of view.
And as a result of that,
I'm going to do everything
I can to keep pressing those
perspectives and I think
if any issue I have with
some of the millennials
that I've had the opportunity
to work up close with,
don't be compliant.
You know, just, you are taught sometimes
winning is the path of least resistance
and I think this is now
more than ever your voice
and you know, being willing
to put yourself in harm's way.
It's like the question of losing a job.
I know it sounds like I'm being flip.
I have often asked
myself do I belong here,
should I walk out, nothing is worth this.
And you know, I think that you know,
just really pushing
yourself to understand that.
Sometimes just certain
things, you're just going
to have to walk away if
you really, really, really
believe that you've got
to stand up for something.
So you know, I went to this
program at The Aspen Institute,
the Henry Crown Fellows
program and we were in these
small leadership groups,
20 people and Skip Battle,
who's this amazing guy and
known in Silicon Valley
was my moderator.
I have so much respect
and admiration for him.
And one day we were in the
room and he said to me,
Mellody I know you will do good.
I was like 30 days old.
He goes, but will you stand in harm's way?
Will you put yourself in harm's way?
He said you could go
through your whole life
just doing the easy path and
feeling good about yourself
and patting yourself on your back,
but will you allow yourself to be hurt?
Will you allow yourself to
have a tremendous setback
because you stood up
for what you believed?
And that forced me to really think about
the path of least resistance
and saying versus believing
that I will allow myself to be harmed.
And then I started to
think about people like
John Lewis standing on
the Edmund Pettus Bridge
and I started to think, I literally
cannot say this without welling up,
saying could I have that kind of courage?
And I think this is the moment
we're standing in right now.
We have to have that John Lewis courage,
that Martin Luther King
courage, that dogs turned on
teenagers, fire hoses
turned on people courage
'cause I think that if
we were standing there,
if I was standing there,
I think I would run.
Now I'm telling myself stand.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Sarah Green asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next top 10, check out
the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I'd also like to know
what was your favorite
message from this video, what
did you learn from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
in your life or in your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to the Essetino
Artists YouTube channel.
Thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and having me on your show
in an interview to talk about it.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- We're interviewing
author of Your One Word,
Evan Carmichael live
on our YouTube channel.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- If you follow your passion,
you're going to be successful
no matter what because
one, you'll be happy,
and I think happiness is really important.
You can't do anything
well if you're not happy.
You can't be a good parent, good spouse,
girlfriend, boyfriend, you
can't be a good co-worker.
Happiness is important
and that doesn't mean
euphoria everyday, but
a basic sense of peace
and for some of us, especially
Type A and especially
hard on ourselves, we
don't give each other,
give ourselves a break and
so the pursuit of happiness
as we have it written
obviously in our Declaration
of Independence is something
that is challenging.
So pursuing happiness
I do think is important
as pursuit of anything else.
Observe your environment,
at work, at school, at home.
I'm asking you to look
at the people around you.
Purposefully and
intentionally invite people
into your life who don't look like you,
don't think like you, don't act like you,
don't come from where you come from
and you might find that
they will challenge
your assumptions and make
you grow as a person.
You might get powerful new
insights from these individuals.
Some of our best ideas
also come from pushing
something that other
people are afraid to do.
So we've innovated in
areas that cause people
some trepidation and I think that's just
the part of us that is a little irreverent
and the part of us that's willing
to be very very different.
So it's everything from
having a turtle as a logo
when Merryl has a scary
bull and Drefyus has a lion.
And we have this turtle
holding a loving cup
that was a drawing and you
know looks very friendly.
That was very different.
So we had this turtle, it
was John's original logo
for Ariel and then we just blew it out.
I mean all of our materials
look like storybooks
and our brochure was like a storybook
and people would get them and say
I took this home.
And then you knew you
had something special.